Madam President let me be very frank
while the bailout package we are dealing
with tonight is far better than the
absurd proposal that was originally
presented to us by the Bush
administration which if you can believe
it would have given the secretary of the
Treasury a blank check to spend seven
hundred billion dollars in any way that
he wanted without any transparency
without any oversight and without any
judicial review this bill far better
than that is still short of where we
should be and I want to thank Senator
Dodd and others for their very hard work
in improving this legislation but in my
view this bill is still not good enough
it should be rejected by the Senate
unless an amendment that I am about to
offer is passed Madam President this
country faces many serious problems in
the financial market in the stock market
in our economy we must act but we must
act in a way that improves the situation
we can do better than the legislation we
are dealing with tonight Madam President
this bill does not effectively address
the issue of what the taxpayers of our
country will actually own after they
invest hundreds of billions of dollars
in toxic assets this bill does not
effectively address the issue of
oversight because the board members the
oversight board members were hand-picked
from the Bush administration this bill
does not effectively deal with the issue
of foreclosures and addressing that very
very serious issue which is impacting
millions of low and moderate income
Americans in the aggressive effective
kind of way that we should be this bill
does not
effectively deal with the issue of
executive compensation and golden
parachutes under this bill the CEOs and
the Wall Street in sight is we'll still
with a little bit of imagination
continue to make out like bandits Madam
President this bill does not deal at all
with how we got into this crisis in the
first place and the need to undo the
deregulation fervor which created
trillions of dollars in complicated and
unregulated financial instruments such
as credit default swaps and hedge funds
this bill does not address the issue
that has taken us to where we are today
the concept of too big to fail the need
for taxpayers to bail out institutions
which are so large that they will cause
systemic damage to our entire economy if
they go bankrupt in fact Madam President
within the last several weeks we have
SAT idly by and watch gigantic financial
institutions like the bank of america
swallow up other gigantic financial
institutions like countrywide and
merrill lynch merrill lynch well who is
going to bail out the bank of america if
it begins to todd not one word about the
issue of too big to fail in this
legislation at a time when that problem
is in fact becoming even more serious
Madam President this bill does not deal
with the absurdity of having the fox
guarding the hen house now maybe I'm the
only Marik person in America who thinks
so but I have a hard time understanding
why we are giving seven hundred billion
dollars to the secretary of the Treasury
who was the former CEO of Goldman Sachs
who along with other financial
institutions actually got us in
to this problem now maybe I'm the only
person in America who thinks that's a
little bit weird but that is what I
think but a president this bill does not
address the major economic crises we
face growing unemployment low wages and
the need to create decent paying jobs
rebuilding our infrastructure and moving
us to energy efficiency and sustainable
energy but on top of all that Madam
President there is one issue that is
even more profound and more basic than
everything else that I have mentioned
and that is if a bailout is needed if
taxpayer money must be placed at risk
whose money should it be in other words
who should be paying for this bailout
which has been caused by the greed and
recklessness of Wall Street operatives
who have made billions in recent years
and that Madam President is what my
amendment is all about and it is an
issue that we have got to bring to the
floor because that is what the American
people want to hear discuss Madam
President the American people are bitter
they are angry and they are confused
over the last seven years since George W
Bush has been president six million
Americans have slipped out of the middle
class and are in poverty and today
working families are lining up at
emergency food shelves in order to get
the food they need to feed their
families but a president since President
Bush has been in office median family
income for working-age families has
declined by over two thousand dollars
seven million Americans have lost their
health insurance four million have lost
their pensions consumer debt has more
than doubled and foreclosures are the
highest on record meanwhile the cost of
energy food health
College and other basic necessities has
soared Madam President while the middle
class has declined on the President
Bush's reckless economic policies the
people on top have never had it so good
for the first seven years of Bush's
tenure the wealthiest 400 individuals in
our country sorreh 670 billion dollar
increase in their wealth and at the end
of 2007 owned over one and a half
trillion dollars in wealth that is just
400 families 670 billion dollar increase
in wealth since Bush has been in office
Madam President in our country today we
have the most unequal distribution of
income and wealth of any major country
on Earth with the top one percent
earning more income than the bottom
fifty percent and the top one percent
owning more wealth than the bottom
ninety percent Madam President we are
living at a time when we have seen a
massive transfer of wealth from the
middle class to the very wealthiest
people in this country when among others
CEOs of Wall Street firms received
unbelievable amounts in bonuses
including 39 billion dollars in bonuses
in the year 2007 alone for just the five
major investment houses we have seen the
incredible greed of the financial
service industry manifested in the
hundreds of millions of dollars they
have spent on campaign contributions and
lobbyists in order to deregulate their
industry so that hedge funds and other
unregulated unregulated financial
institutions could flourish we have seen
them play with trillions and trillions
of dollars in esoteric financial
instruments in unregulated industries
which no more than a handful of people
even understand we have seen the
financial services industry charge
thirty percent interest rates on credit
card loans and tack on outrageous late
fees and other costs to unsuspecting
customers we are seeing them engaged in
Despicable predatory lending practices
taking advantage of the vulnerable and
the uneducated we have seen them send
out billions of deceptive solicitations
to almost every mailbox in America I
used to think that my home was the only
one that was receiving them turns out
that billions of other solicitations
went out to probably every home in
America and what they hope to do was to
gain new customers for credit card
companies and then through the very
small print in the back of the
solicitation have the opportunity have
the ability to monkey around with
interest rates so when people thought
they were getting zero interest or two
percent turns out that a few months
later they were paying very very high
interest rates most importantly of
course we have seen the financial we
have seen the financial services
industry lure people into mortgages they
could not afford to pay which is one of
the basic reasons why we are here
tonight Madam President in the midst of
all of this we have a bailout package
today which says to the middle class
that you are being asked the place at
risk seven hundred billion dollars which
is 2200 dollars for every man woman and
child in this country and you're being
asked to do that in order to undo the
damage caused by this excessive Wall
Street greed in other words the masters
of the universe those brilliant Wall
Street insiders who have made more money
than the average of
American can even dream of have wrought
our financial system to the brink of
collapse and now as the American and
world financial systems tietam on the
edge of a meltdown these multi
millionaires are demanding that the
middle class which has already suffered
on the bushes disastrous economic
policies pick up the pieces that they
broke that is wrong and that is
something that I will not support Madam
President the major point I want to make
this evening is that if we are going to
bail out Wall Street it should be those
people who have caused the problem those
people who have benefited from Bush's
tax breaks for millionaires and
billionaires those people who have taken
advantage of deregulation those people
are the people who should pick up the
tab and not ordinary working people by
the president I have introduced an
amendment which gives the Senate a very
clear choice we can pay for this bailout
of Wall Street by asking people all
across this country small businesses on
Main Street homeowners on Maple Street
elderly couples on Oak Street college
students on campus Avenue working
families on sunrise lane we can ask them
to pay for this bailout that is one way
we can go all Madam President we can ask
the people who have gained the most from
the spasm of greed the people whose
incomes have been soaring under
President Bush to pick up the tab they
threw the party they became drunk on
greed and now I believe they should foot
the bill what my amendment proposes is
quite simple it proposes to raise the
tax rate on any individual earning five
hundred thousand a year or more or any
family Ernie 1 million dollars a year or
more by ten percent batt 10
cent increase in the tax rate from
thirty five percent to forty five
percent will raise over three hundred
billion dollars in the next five years
three hundred billion is almost half the
cost of the Bella if what all the
supporters of this legislation are
saying is correct that the government
will get back some of its money when the
market comes down and the government
sells some of the assets it has
purchased this amount of 300 billion
should be sufficient to make sure that
99.7 percent of taxpayers do not have to
pay one nickel for this Bella by the
president most of my constituents did
not earn a 38 million dollar bonus in
2005 or make over 100 million in total
compensation in three years as did mr.
henry paulson current Secretary of the
Treasury and former CEO of Goldman Sachs
Madam President most of my constituents
did not make three hundred and fifty
four million dollars in total
compensation over the past five years as
that Richard fooled the CEO of Lehman
Brothers Madam President most of my
constituents did not cash out 60 million
dollars in stock after a 29 billion
dollar bailout for Bear Stearns after
that failing company was bought out by
jpmorgan chase but a president most of
my constituents did not get a 161
million-dollar severance package as East
Stanley O'Neill former CEO of Merrill
Lynch did Madame president last week I
placed on my website sanders that senate
gov a letter to secretary Paulson in
support of the content of my amendment
which is pretty simple it said that it
should be those people
that's stable to pay for this bailout
those people who have made out like
bandits in recent years they should be
asked to pay for this bailout and it
should not be the middle class and to my
amazement and I'm a senator from a small
state to my amazement some 48,000 people
and here they are these are their names
and I will not read them or wolf Madam
President forty-eight thousand people
have already co signed this petition and
the names keep coming in and the message
is very simple we had nothing to do with
causing this bailout we are already on
the economic the rest go to those people
who have made out like bandits go to
those people who have caused this crisis
and ask them to pay for the bailout
Madam President the time has come to
assure our constituents in Vermont and
all over this country that we are
listening and understand their anger and
their frustration the time has come to
say that we have the courage to stand up
to all of the powerful financial
institution lobbyists who are running
amok all over this building from the
Chamber of Commerce to the American
Bankers Association to the Business
Roundtable all of these huge campaign
contributions spend all kinds of money
on lobbyists they're here loud and clear
they don't want to pay for this bailout
they want Middle America to pay for that
so this is a moment of truth Madam
President I have I hope very much that
this Senate will support our the
amendment that I have offered and at
this point I would yield I would